hey guys how's it going so I'm super
excited because I just hit 3 million
subscribers and I'm currently in the
process of editing the vlog that you're
going to see right after this but I felt
like I should say hello and thank you
and I'm super excited and it's kind of
crazy that so many of you guys have
actually been here for all 10 years so
if you are a a 10 year subscriber save
something in the comments even if you
don't even subscribe for a day which
technically you some of you may have
only been subscribed for like an hour
because that's how things work so
welcome to the old and the new
subscribers I can't tell you the future
plans of this channel because I get
bored easily
and things change quickly but what I can
tell you is tomorrow I have an exciting
3 million subscriber video explanation
of what will be happening in the next
week of videos with that being said
here's the vlog of me getting this
carpet it's really riveting content and
for those asking Veda is vlog every day
in August night I had three million
subscribers on YouTube do you care do
you care no cool hi YouTube how's it
going like what has happened to this
place I'm not even sure having a really
exciting day today I know you guys saw
in a previous vlog where I was talking
about getting a carpet well we did some
measurements today and guess what the
carpet will fit gonna need a little
assistance though from some friends
because you'll see why right now I'm
going to get my eyebrows done it's
really exciting times you know just got
to do what you got to do being a girl is
great love it I also can't find my other
camera if I'm filming on a GoPro right
now is that really great charging
station over here where most electronics
go to charge we need charged 70d and 3a
7s mark 2
GPS they're ruining this interesting I'm
not parking that where the parking was
already paid I felt like an hour and a
half to just really take in the sights
over here what Steven this outfit I
don't even know anymore I think I'm
going through a third life crisis kind
of thing yeah I sell difference Kenya
there was a point in my internet career
I guess she would call it that they were
Tumblr posts because my eyebrows were so
bad now I'm the garbage Ellison
we're on our way to Dunkin Donuts I'm
kidding it turns out I'm gonna get iced
coffee yes light cream light cream and
then we're going to get the carpet the
carpet dilemma continues we'll say maybe
we should hold on admission would know
which Street is Lunchables well you
could have a lot of parking tickets from
that's two times that I've gone there
I've gotten parking tickets they don't
wanna go City what what is this parking
and I open it I was like well I don't
remember what's here and I was like I
think it's the location of Dunkin Donuts
it was
there's no stop here Oh God we're saying
it will help you to say no hello who are
you to call me late in the night
let's discuss hey where's the line I
don't know actually
actually I think I'm perfect it's uh
it's good there's nobody else here so I
mean clearly if Shu parked next to me
you want to be my friend should I buy a
nice clean up no you'll kill it
I've watered your plant for the past
year water actually over here so Jenna
kept telling me that the carpet was not
gonna fit in her car associated to drive
mhm
I said he would be able to bed at a
power wheel okay wait we want to show
you guys the carpet that we're gonna get
Cheryl a car huh turn my car I've never
driven your car looks good okay that
would have fit in your car oh you make
me so mad oh yeah it is I just seen your
car right ever thought about the fold
method classic fill me up fill me up AC
buttercup baby don't let's do this I'm
glad that's coming over to help at so
pulpy help Orton and says that he can
solve any problems well I've got a
problem we need to solve and that's how
do we get this carpet underneath my desk
ed wants to know if you want Starbucks
Cinda thank you no thank you I've
already had like 17 cups of coffee it's
been a really wild day a lot of things
happened a lot of things nothing
actually a lot of stuff happened but
like nothing has actually happened I've
been trying to accomplish so many things
but I'm not sure I got my eyebrows done
Harry yeah
hey you don't know how this you
can't really tell that you know I was
winning no real aerodynamic today Oh
baby baby
hashtag Katie V this is what we came to
eat it I'm not sure why blue my GoPro I
can't find my other camera the audio is
gonna be great you think Nick no the
audios good on you oh is it yeah
especially cause it's super close to my
face I'm gonna vlog on my thing here
we're just I'm just
yeah it's 360
for anyone
my
the TV is way too big huge kitchen TV so
yeah you crazy it's this many more
inches too big that many that's a lot of
inches so something really cool is on a
bridge it'll show you what's in your
fridge we're gonna put some stuff in
here so I just put his keys in there
okay let's put my phone in what phone
and he he put up a front facing facing
area
great
overdue potatoes okay look look it's us
let's measure water that's cool all
right
it's fun it's five days old was it hey
did I leave my phone in the fridge again
I think I did when was it fall one day a
pre-dinner but look my phone's in the
fridge at keys wait a minute right one
day save oh my god do we believe oh why
did it fall cuz this whole fridge is not
stable here's an energy box is where the
carpets gonna go here what we need to
figure out though is how do we get it
over here because those tables are
extremely heavy I say we move this couch
yes that needs to be moved
are you still alive oh God
oh my gosh thank you
this is amazing that I don't a story it
looks real nice Wow
what do you guys think I don't know look
at it through my camera house here
yeah oh great yeah real nice cool well
let's go eat food and then I'm gonna
vacuum and then we can do the couch and
then we're done and then we turn up hey
none of the place it's really nice
that's ah yep